Jesse Harris, Filmmaker: They basically looked
at it and said Okay, Lucy Hale, this script,
we think it's this much money we can make off of
it. So this is what we'll offer to you. Even then
they don't give you the money to go make it. You
then have to still find someone else to usually
finance that contract, basically it's almost
like collateral you use to kind of then go make.
Film Courage: If we took your pitch [for
Borrego movie], how much of it was about
the idea of the film and how much
was about the return on investment?
Jesse: I think it's probably a 50/50 kind
of pitch in terms of the creative side and
the financial side. I mean obviously it depends
on who you're pitching. When it's an actor or
something like that it's all about the character
and all about the story. When it's an investor,
it's much more on the financial side but hopefully
the people you're working with do care about
making a good movie and that was the case in my
case. But ultimately making movies is a business
and unless you could finance it yourself,
you have to kind of work within that system.
I felt confident though that this film could
be financially successful because it wasn't
some sort of quiet indie drama, it was a really
compelling kind of commercial film but with a lot
more to it. If you look at the trailers that the
distributors made, it's a very commercial version
of the movie. There’s actually a lot more depth
than in the film when you actually watch it but
they are able to market it as a broader kind of
commercial action movie and that's going to bring
people in. When they watch it they're going
to hopefully be pleasantly surprised. There's
actually so much more to it. It's not so much
that. It really is a much deeper, complex film.
But I knew that that's how you could do it and
that would that would be a model that would work
and so we also the movie is not a very expensive
movie and we we made it for as little as budget
as possible and we put a lot into it and we
were able to make a really great looking film
on a pretty small indie budget still and so I
think it's in a place now where because of all
that I think it will hopefully make its money back
and be successful and I think it's an interesting
size film that I think we could be doing more of
these kind of couple million dollar films where
it it has this blending of genres and worlds
where there's there is some risk still because
you're trying to tell maybe a more
deeper story but it's not just this
I think we Hollywood needs to take a little bit
more risk but there could also be some calculated
risks like this which is not everything has to
be some sort of sequel or remake or whatever like
there is there are sizes of films that still
make sense where it's it still could make its
money back it still has a good shot at being
a very successful film but it's still telling
a new fresh original story with a unique cast
and maybe really almost first time director so
I hope it's it'll be a I hope if it's successful
it'll prove and show that they can be taking more
chances on people like me how much do investors
care about movie ideas movie ideas I mean I think
if it's a good investor they they care about the
idea and the the concept certain investors don't
care at all and they just want to see who's in it
and what the genre is and what the the dollars and
all that stuff is what is a tax incentive and all
that kind of things and unfortunately that's how
a lot of movies get made but that's also why we
end up with a lot of not so good movies too so
I think the best case is when you kind of think
of it from both sides you you obviously need to
understand this is a business it has to make
money and have a shot of that but you still
have to make a compelling good movie otherwise
what's the point because we're only doing this
to entertain people and make good stories so I
was lucky to have investors that wanted to make
a good film and so hopefully that's where
people want to kind of go towards when you're
when you're trying to make your film I definitely
met with people who didn't have that that vision
and and I didn't make the movie with them
so I think it is about trying to be patient
and and I probably could have made the movie a
little bit sooner if I had made more compromises
creatively but I was pretty clear on certain
things specifically authentic cast and
making the film in a certain style and in actual
real locations that that fit the story and
not shooting in New Mexico or something that
just fit totally out of place just because
it had a good incentive or something and so it
definitely probably took a little bit longer but
in the end it made a really great film by kind
of holding out a little bit longer probably
so from your experience in 2003 when you were a
teenager and you made a feature do you think the
concept the idea was important at that time
to those distributors versus now it's it's
just much different it's a machine well so
I think that first feature I made when I was
in high school it got picked up from a distributor
because I think they could tell a bigger story by
this 17 year old had made a feature film like
that's kind of was the selling I was the star
of that movie I guess so I don't think it's
changed a whole lot obviously there's there's
more and more opportunities now for distribution
than ever and so I still think there's lots of
opportunities and there's lots of smart good
distributors that want to make good things but
unfortunately there still are a lot of movies that
are made more from the financial only sense and
not just is this a really good movie that's gonna
people are gonna enjoy because I think also people
they when sometimes when they analyze a movie only
from the money side they forget that the creative
is a money side too like if the movie's crap then
it doesn't mean the movie's gonna be successful
just because it fits everything else and so
and if you make a really good film it'll still
probably it can still be successful so I think
it still should all be it should be all around
the story and the script unfortunately it isn't
but hopefully more films are successful of this
kind of size that are like that that hopefully
that can that can change some things okay so you
have a name attached you have someone who has a
fan base then how how does the money then follow
yeah so I had written the script I had made this
proof of concept I had gotten Lucy Hale attached
to star in it and then it still took two years
to go make the movie after that so yeah because
we still had to find the money basically
we had her value now which gave the movie
an actual way to kind of have value to for people
to see that it could make money once it got made
but we still had to get people to to
commit to a certain dollar amount we
had to then just find the actual people that
wanted to invest in that our model was after
so Lucy she signed on she actually kind of came
on also as an executive producer to kind of
say hey I’ll help you try to go get
this made too a little bit and so
she sent the script to a producer he came on board
to help me he was excited about it he took it some
more producers that's kind of how it always works
right it just kind of goes on to the next person
they eventually were able to get us it's called
an mg or minimum guarantee and it's basically a
distributor pre-buying the movie before you even
made it just off the script and the cast so they
basically looked at it and said okay Lucy Hale
this script we think it's this much money we can
make off of it so this is what we'll offer it
to you and so even then they don't give you
the money to go make it you then have to still
find someone else to usually finance that that
contract basically it's almost like collateral
you use to kind of then go make it so that's
how we did it that was our model and so that's
that's how we were able to get the movie made
and yeah I mean it's it it still took a long time
and this was also like right we were supposed to
go make the movie or hoping to go make the movie
and then cope it happened so that pushed just off
again and had another delay and so it's it's
just never and even when you think it's all
put together or something falls apart and so it's
it's a whole process I was a producer on the movie
but my other three other producers were really
the key people in terms of the financial side so
they were really the ones getting that money and
putting that together and and managing all that
so I can't speak to all of it in super detail but
it's definitely a complicated process that is it's
it you never know what's gonna happen next
basically with it so the fact too that Lucy Hale
was an executive producer and was sort of helping
to shepherd the movie probably was incredibly
helpful as well for sure I mean having her name
attached as an actress is huge but then having her
as vouching for it as as a really strong project
that she wants to put her weight behind was was
super essential I mean just legitimized
the project and opened more doors I mean
it's funny though even when you have someone
famous attached it could still be really hard it's
just so hard to get a movie made no matter who it
is trying to to make it I think they they make it
as difficult as possible and but I think if you
just keep going and never give up it will usually
find a way were there any things where let's say
you were all boarding a plane ready to film and
something fell through luckily we didn't have
anything fall through too late in the game I
think the biggest thing was just we shot the film
in Spain we ended up doing that because we we had
to basically the time window we were going to
originally make this was in the spring of 2020
which of course was when was coming and shutting
the world down so then we had this window in the
fall when we thought we could go make it somewhere
because the world was starting to open up again at
least in Europe but after we waited too long Lucy
and other people might not be available anymore
so we knew if we were going to make it this year
as in 2020 when we made it we had to go then and
the only place we could really do that was was
not in California where we were set because
everything was still so much more closed down to
get the permits at the state park and everything
were already going to be complicated but even
during covet it was just almost impossible
and so I had been looking at other countries
and places to film the movie before this even
just to kind of to explore what opportunities
there were and Spain has this desert that looks
almost identical to California desert to the
desert of Anza Borrego [near San Diego] where
the movie is set and that was not my first
choice originally and it's not what I
ever thought was the right move to go all the way
to Spain just to make the movie that's set here
but it ended up being probably the perfect thing
because the desert it was such a perfect match
and then it allowed us our money actually went a
lot further in Spain because one is there's a tax
incentive for the whole country for filming but
then just the crew and other things that the money
I think it allowed us to get probably even more
for our money I mean you obviously lose money too
on exchanging to euros and flying people over
there and all that stuff but in the end of the day
we found a great group of people that wanted to
help us make this movie and and we made a really
great film there and so it all worked out but
I think yeah the to your particular question it
was the hardest thing was probably just getting
the visas for people to get over there allowing
even the airlines didn't want us and to get
on the plane like because at the time no one
was traveling even Americans weren't allowed to
travel and so the first plane I tried to get on
leaving the airport they wouldn't let us on the
plane because they were worried we wouldn't be
allowed into the country because it was just such
a rare thing for people to be leaving the country
so there was those kind of complications but
once we were there it was just the typical
normal complications of just trying to figure
it out but luckily there weren't any sort of
major drama or anything like that so you had your
boarding pass and maybe a carry-on and they said
sorry sir we can't have you yeah no we
were trying to check in for the plane to go
to Spain and go film a movie and we had a ticket
and everything but the actual agents checking our
bags in basically said like you're not you
you don't have you're missing some pieces
of paperwork or whatever we didn't we had it but
they were just so had never experienced this yet
that an American was leaving the country you'd
go make a movie somewhere that that would be
allowed by the Spanish government and so it was
just it was just so new to everyone no one this
was in August/September of 2020 was just still so
fresh still in the middle of the pandemic really.
What do you like about this video?